c'est non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
superman est il un vrai français
voilà une question intelligente et qu'on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de se poser quand
on sait que superman ne sauve
pratiquement jamais personne le jour de
la pâque russe
quoi qu'il en soit pour savoir si
superman est français ou non le plus
simple est d'aller demander à sa grand
mère je me trouve chez super mamie est
super papy les grands-parents de
superman à première vue ils ont l'air
parfaitement français mais cela reste à
prouver
regardez bien on y va tapez 1 on y va
maman bien oui vous avez compris super
mamie est super papy sont bretons en
effet ils ont des chapeaux ronds vive la
bretagne
ils ont des chapeaux ronds vive les
bretons ils ont déjà bord où vivaient
les bretons
etonnant non
[Musique]